oui il y a du monde amène-moi de la
viande là
c'est bon mon bébé c'est bon oui c'est
bon moi j'ai ça
alors le retour des bras ton numéro
crawl c'est une question que j'ai
souvent en fait ce qui est important
c'est pas forcément le retour aérien
mais c'est plutôt ce qui se passe sous
l'eau alors les gens connaissent
énormément le vélo c'est un peu pareil
ceux qui font de la piste ils mettent un
braquet plus gros donc si tu fais du
plat tu vas mettre un braquet plus gros
et si tu fais de la montagne va falloir
s'économiser et mettre un marqué plus
petit
Angoulême
bonjour aujourd'hui on fait une piste
trop chelou
c'est parti
on rentre dans un tunnel
je vois rien avec le masque
ah c'est trop stylée avec les lumières
le premier qui fait déborder ce vase
finit la tête dans les toilettes avec la
chasse d'eau tirée je commence
la tête dans les chiottes non ça va
[Musique]
[Rires]